Continental Tire coaches corner
Continental Tire proud to be the
exclusive tire the Dan Patrick show no
matter where you drive or what you drive
Continental designs tires for what you
do for more info visit Continental Tire
Continental Tire for what you do coach
Roy Williams how late was the
celebration coach how late was the
celebration is that was head down yeah
okay I guess it's still going on I tried
to go to bed for a couple of hours and
it didn't work it's still seven am out
here in Phoenix we're leaving in about
three hours but I'm getting too old for
the big celebrations we basically came
up about 3:00 a.m. and what Sports
Center so we can see it what did you see
when you were watching the Highlander
some big plays and it was kind of thing
where usually I can remember almost
every play in the sequence but last
night the whole game was so disjointed
and so uneven or you simply say so ugly
you know I got up to the room and I'm
thinking wait did this happen before
that happen did that happen for this so
it was good for me to see it because the
emotion that in the game I was having a
difficult time putting together what
order things were going but it's a
fantastic feeling to sit there know when
Joe Barry shot that ball it was going in
or when they were going to take a shot
without I'm just going to be did you
have to have your team adjust to the
refereeing listening you know I've been
asked that a lot because evidently it
was talked about a lot but well we knew
in ourselves that it could get to be up
and down game like the first game we
played Kentucky 103 100 over but we also
knew it could be always easier time
another terminology of slugfest
so I really never got that totally
involved with officiating I was just
trying to coach our team I got mad one
once or twice for sure especially when
you know they said the ball was out of
bounds on us and the kid didn't hit the
ball they gave them another possession
it was a three-point shot but you know
it both Kings defenses were a lot
stronger than their offense it was ours
they just made us take bad shots and in
our defense forced 14 turnovers
it was an ugly game that the whistles
it's part of the game I try to get my
guys to focus on that because kids just
always think they got to have somebody
else to bail them out and I tell them go
ahead and make connect I'm playing and
don't worry about the referees do you
work the officials differently
international tunnel game I don't but
I'm try I think that's really overplayed
most the time I tell them I'm not I'd
like to coach the game and never speak
to him direct course of the game but it
doesn't quite happen very often does
this reinvigorate you does it make you
want to coach longer you know I enjoyed
last year except for the last couple
seconds I enjoyed what that club did
this you know gives you the emotion and
some sensational feeling that you have
for your kids and that they're going to
be in North Carolina basketball history
forever but I don't think I'll ever let
that make a decision on how long I coach
as long as I enjoy it as much as they do
and enjoy the kids and you know I mean
we got some Looney Tunes on our team we
have a lot of fun does impending
sanctions or whatever happens with the
NCAA investigation impact what you're
coaching future will be no you know I've
said this I got to get so tired of
talking about it but I said this I used
to think I wanted to make sure that it
was over with before I retired now I
want to make sure that it's over with
before I die what will happen
are you planning and taking the team to
the winners we haven't even talked about
it and I did one writer asked me about
it
maybe before Saturday giving us on
Friday and I told him you don't know
where he lives because I am NOT talking
about anything I'm going to do I am a
little bit superstitious big fella and
last night he asked me the same thing
and I said heck in 2005 we never got
invited so those we're going to get
invited kind of thing but I really
haven't thought it I have a great deal
of respect for the office of the
presidency of the United States there's
no question about that but I haven't
thought about it other than answering
his question last night of years right
now what are you going to do with that
sports coat you know that's a good
question that suckers getting pretty
good
yeah I don't know if I want to retire it
I'm able to keep it around but yeah it's
its record is about as good as any food
I've ever had but I would frame it coke
I mean guys supreme their Jersey Oh
Freeman sport coat well I've got one
from the 2005 national championship team
is in our Museum in Chapel Hill so I
wouldn't just put it in close and leave
it there that's for sure was Michael
Jordan not there because he was
superstitious did you hear this
people ask me the last day and a half if
he was going to comment I said he has a
close up of guys knowing him he's going
to say I went it last year and you lost
and so that's what I was thinking and
our system maybe Clank Walt Lee we were
walking to the bus last night and I said
I want to bet you a dollar I said I'll
give you about any odds you want I said
but I'll bet you there's a text message
from Michael or a voicemail from Michael
it and he's gonna say something about
coming last year and sure enough I got
on the bus and got my phone out of my
backpack so I left it on the bus I had
quite a few messages and when I was
Michael so I collected some money last
night would you rather have good seniors
or great freshmen oh man you can need to
win it you got to have one of the two
there's no question and you can make the
argument over the last 10 or 15 years
it's probably 50/50 of what kind of
teams have wanted but I would say either
one you know I love coaching kids and
getting that relationship that you can
have for four years but you know Anthony
Davis his freshman year or a couple guys
like I've had Marvin leaves Brandon
right I would take them any time - even
though it's only a one year coaching
deal Marvin Williams is one of those
text messages last night Brandan Wright
was one of those messages and I love
them dearly so I'll take either one just
to let you know you're the warm-up back
for Jack Nicklaus in ten minutes so
you're okay I'm you know I'm going to go
play in a charity event that is
sponsored by the mr. Nicholas and his
wife and mid June I think
have you met him we're close to
Washington DC I met him once or twice
just to say hello when his son Jackie
was in school and I think he would
Know Who I am but I'm not sure and
that's okay because I know who he is
I think college basketball certainly
knows who you are coach congratulations
with your third title and hopefully you
get a little rest before you hit the
recruiting trail well we're going to get
the recruiting trail on Thursday because
that's what I can go back out but I'm
looking forward to the golf course 3d
operations last two summers and I'm
taking the summer off from knee surgery
this summer so I could play some golf
Danny Thank You Roy
Congrats thank you very much there
that's Roy Williams Continental Tire
coaches corner Continental Tire for what
you do a little bit tired they're going
to hit the recruiting trail third
national title one more than his idol
Dean Smith put you up there put you up
there with you know great coaches of all
time number of times you've been to a
Final Four winning the three titles he's
there with Coach K Tom Izzo Rick Pitino
Bill Self the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience